Now that we have seen how, the semantic network knowledge representation,
enables problem solving, let us return to that earlier problem that we
were talking about. The problem of A is to B, as C is to 5.
Recall that we have worked out the representations for both A is to B and
C is to 5. The question now becomes, whether we can use this representation,
to decide whether or not 5 is the correct answer. If we look at
the two representations in detail, then we see part of the representation here,
is the same as the representation here. Except that, this part is different from
this part. Here we have y expanded and right here, we have s remain unchanged.
So this may not be the best answer. Perhaps there is a better answer. Where
the representation on the left, will exactly match representation on the right.